the Joe Rogan experience well you know
Joe it was like it you could do whatever
you wanted yeah
come we started comedy in Boston so
there were no rules and if there were
any rules we'd break the rules and we
made up our own rules and that's right
like today you see how it is that today
I really enjoy working theaters but the
clubs you know the other day this person
had come I hate people say you suck over
hecklers you know why cuz I hate them I
don't want to deal with them I want to
do the show I want to create I want to
mix em but they stay throw you off
you're getting going and they're
breaking my man and you say [ __ ] that
you know and they start crying I'm
trying to do a show fear yeah okay okay
approach I'm sorry anything our plane
had a guy I did a I think for
dana-farber the other night raised more
money than they ever met race it was
great it was in all thing with a saint a
farmer date dana farber it's cancer
cancer research you know it's like the
Jimmy Fund and stuff like that
so that's me I said sure I'll do it so
it was nice it was big event the
Mandarin army had told fantastical
everything and this guy comes out to
because you know everyone likes you but
I hate you I want to rip your face off
and I go hey it's nice to meet you too
right so he grabs my water I go you can
have it I walk away to take a picture so
I come back and you want I go you can
have it now you you know I don't know
why people like you but I hate you and
I'm gonna rip your face up I go yeah
yeah I said we had this conversation so
not people however hey Lenny can we talk
get the [ __ ] away from Sydney screaming
at people yes you you attacked my father
on stage 20 years ago on a Thursday
night at Granite like someone well I
don't remember what I did last Thursday
say idea father he's dying oh hey man I
had nothing to do it I've been guy
wasn't say day eventually had him
exported out by security it was really
wild but I mean Jesus yeah you know I
mean look well it shows your hecklers
make weak babies oh man yeah well you
know what makes a dumb kid no don't [ __ ]
with somebody if you're not I mean
haven't done a 42 years or a married but
MIT two or three times you know it's a
there's a lot of [ __ ] I've covered
you're not gonna you know you're like my
surprise
it's a Larry's take on you can have that
water
I've never had security in my life you
know because I'm a man pretty I still
take the teachers for shits and giggles
but I mean you know Wow crazy
yeah well cuz I'm thinking punch him in
his throat and he'll just drop to his
knees and don't even know what happened
I'll say we need a medic you know get
well and then I was gonna whispers why
don't you meet me outside ten minutes
uncle I can't do that man yeah I was all
dressed nice and oh if you're gonna
punch some of the throat though the
promise sometimes you Nick the chin the
real way to do it is this mmm this with
your hand yeah just slam that [ __ ]
thing in the throat right in there
that's how you do it oh if you punch
someone in the throat yeah first first
of all you could say I pushed him away
from me right right I [ __ ] that up now
someone's gonna say but that's how you
if you want to hit someone in the throat
yeah and you don't want to really hurt
him you want to get him the [ __ ] away
from you yeah just use your open hand
like that your open hand just like that
it's amazing how much force you can
generate with you're just slamming a
hand you don't have to wind up which no
just this is a tender area it's very
vulnerable that's what's going through
my mind well this guy screaming at me
right like I couldn't believe it I said
Jesus you know yeah it's unfortunate huh
but there's there's always gonna be
[ __ ] people that are unhinged oh he's
always gonna be people that can't hang
but what's really amazing Lenny is the
amount of shows that we do how many
people keep it together
yes live show ladies and gentlemen Lenny
Clarke it's all live it's happening you
know this is not some program thing I
don't know where I'm going
frankly all right oh you treat me good
I'll treat you better you come with me
I'll follow you home and burn your house
today I just want to make you laugh my
money I have no hidden agenda about
paying the bills you know I mean yeah
because to do stand-up now is is so much
different than before because the reward
you can't say words you know like you
can but know what's not hey it's not me
I can't no you're looking at an old
white man couple more years down the
road I'll be able to say whatever I want
it's just elderly I mean right I started
paper the other day some kids beat up
this 63 year old guy and it's a big like
federal case against him because he's
elderly I'm 66 you know and I'm not
going down like that guy you know this
kid's gonna be surprised now go look I'm
elderly you know it's a pretty yeah oh
Jesus Christ
[Applause]